legault trouvent les étapes assez
difficile mais il faut qu'on me tiens et
il demande pour les foules éditions
passées moi j'y tiens à faire des
foulées du sud tour des années parce que
c'est une compétition très demandée
c'est un peu familial c'est la 26e
édition simple et familiale ils ont ils
ont envie de se revoir à cette date
alors l'an dernier c'était général de la
donne du la mairie sportive et fin déjà
félix gray stars se sont imposés cette
année dans le peloton il y aura il y
aura des coureurs redoutent les uns
c'est important également que les amis
de l'historienne c'est très important
pratiquement le recommander
vainqueur bolat il est là il avait
inventé dès qu'il est venu ici c'est
pratiquement un garde du corps de
margaret parce que boule à thé la toux
les années y'a pas de problème et le
guadeloupéen s'est pas autres preneurs
de defour le dessus toutes les étapes
sont tactique même la première étape je
ne vais pas dû le prologue le prologue
c'est juste l'attribution du maillot
mais toutes les étapes sont difficiles
et actes et particulièrement la dernière
étape qui est une étape que le maire de
ducos voulait à tout prix c'est ce qu'on
appelait souvent le championnat de ducos
c'est le 9 km de ducos et celles à cette
date véritable vous allez voir c'est
très très difficile et est acté